these ambulance workers are angry in
their own words they are done
they do an incredible job in the
toughest of circumstances and face real
pressures getting through this cost of
living crisis our message to the
government is clear
talk pay now
instead they've made things worse by
demonizing ambulance workers Who
provided life and limb cover on strike
days
the same people who left picket lines to
rush to save lives the government is
playing politics
playing games with their scare mongering
the people of our country will not have
it
public support for ambulance workers has
been incredible
it's clear the only way to resolve this
dispute is to make GMB ambulance workers
a proper pay offer but it seems the cold
dead hands of number 10 and 11 Downing
Street are stopping this from happening
in the face of government in action we
are left with no option but to take
industrial action
gmb's National ambulance committee has
agreed the following National strike
days
Monday the 6th of February
Monday the 20th of February
Monday the 6th of March Monday the 20th
of March
the NHS trust that will be affected a
Northeast Ambulance Service Northwest
Ambulance Service Yorkshire Ambulance
Service the Welsh Ambulance Service East
Midlands Ambulance Service Southwest
Ambulance Service South Central
Ambulance Service and South East Coast
Ambulance Service
in addition members at West Midlands
ambulance service will be taking strike
action on Monday the 23rd of January and
members at Northwest ambulance service
will be taking strike action on Tuesday
the 24th of January
GMB ambulance workers are determined and
resolute
they're not going to back down
it's up to this government to get
serious on pay we are waiting
thank you
okay so there you have it Rachel
Harrison there from the GMB Union saying
um they've announced four more days
let's bring in Beth so those days but
the 6th of February the 20th of February
the 6th of March on the 20th of March
and Richard Harrison saying there that
they are done and they aren't going to
back down
exactly four more National strikes days
uh two more Regional dates it's
affecting eight ambulance services
across the country and you heard what
the union said the workers are
determined they're not going to back
down it's up to the government they say
to get serious on pay we are waiting so
for more national days of ambulance
strikes announced as we expected
um but still bad news uh for the country
and it was the theme of prime minister's
questions today Kirsten no doubt knew
that this was probably coming and he um
focused all of his questioning around
ambulance sites and the real life
consequences of what it means for people
with with with emergency conditions in
dire need of ambulances and ambulance
not arriving in time I think we have a
um a bit of the exchange there so let's
listen into to what the two leaders had
to say
Mr Speaker it's three minutes past 12.
if somebody phones if somebody phones
999 now because they have chest pains
and fear it might be a heart attack
when would the Prime Minister expect an
ambulance to arrive
[Music]
am I on the Emergency Services when they
need them and that's why we're rapidly
implementing measures to improve the
delivery of ambulance times and indeed
urgent and emergency care but I'd say to
The Honorable gentleman if he cares
about ensuring that patients get access
to life-saving emergency care when they
need it why won't he support our minimum
safety legislation
hmm okay Beth so that was the exchange
there between secure and Rishi sonak um
you've been speaking to the GMB Union
you've been with them this week what
have they been telling you I mean Rachel
Harrison is so categorical there our
message is clear talk pay now
yeah I mean this has been the running
story Kimberly since December the
beginning of December really where uh
the strikes started to pick up and there
was you know a repetition from both the
nurses unions and the ambulance uh
unions and ambulance workers that they
wanted to talk on pay the whole way
through this the government has said we
have done the pay deals we are not
reopening
um the books we are not revisiting
um pay from April 2022 to April 2023 and
neither side are backing down now I as I
was saying earlier I think there are
some glimmers of Hope the Prime Minister
slightly changed position at the
beginning of this year said I do want to
talk he wasn't categorical about
absolutely not talking pay anymore but
the issue that the health secretary
Steve Barkley has is that if he wants to
do a pay deal uh with nurses to improve
salaries and the pay settlement of to
April 2023 at the moment the treasury in
number tennis and you're going to have
to find that from the existing NHS
budget now
um the chancellor Jeremy Hunt uh awarded
an additional 6.6 billion over the next
two years to the NHS uh back in the
Autumn um to help to deal with some of
these emergency backlogs and issues that
have been faced and I guess the question
is or the argument that the health
secretary is saying I will have to take
that out of services budgets to pay
staff more but staff are insistent that
they should be paid more as I was saying
the public are sympathetic to nurses and
ambulance workers rather than the
government and at the moment the
discussions which are all behind
um closed doors is all about whether or
not
um there could be some fudge that kind
of allows the government to say we're
not reopening in Pay deals but allows
the unions to be say we've won more
benefits for our workers and that as I
said could be a one-off payment it could
be back dating next year's pay deal
which begins April 2023 to 24 to back
date that's slightly to give people a
pay lift for the first quarter of this
calendar year do you get the pay rise
for 2023 to 2024 to kick in in April
rather than later in the year that
typically happens these are all things
that have been discussed but I think
what is clear we have two days of
narcissist strikes one today uh one
tomorrow we've got ambulance workers now
striking into February March it is not
going to go away so the question is
whether the pressure ratchets up on the
government to move on pay and I should
say that the nurses Union has moved a
bit you know Pat Colin of the rfcn was
saying we demanded 19 pay rise the
government's saying that's simply
unaffordable and then at the beginning
of this year they came came back and
said actually let's talk about 10 so
there is movement but it is a question
of both sides giving a bit and at the
moment the narciss union is saying okay
we will move a bit on on what we're
asking for and now they're waiting to
see what what the government will do but
it's not really in the gift of the
health secretary this is about in the
end what the treasury and the Prime
Minister will do and that's still a moot
point but I do think that these endless
situations that the prime minister is
now in where week after week he's been
challenged on on these wait times and
these real life examples of of people
losing their lives the pressure's
ratcheting up and as we were talking
earlier just quickly labor issued a
press release about ambulance wait times
claiming 37 000 patients with conditions
like heart attacks and straights waited
for more than three and a half hours for
an ambulance in December and that costs
people's lives and that's people's loved
ones so this is a very emotive issue it
has real life consequences and it's
piling the pressure on the government it
really is but um thank you and his Beth
was saying that that announcement
um that the strikes will now go into
March four new dates the GMB Union
announcing the 6th of February the 20th
of February the 6th of March and the
20th of March now the nurses strike
they've just started a 48-hour strike
today it's affecting Care at 55 NHS
trusts across England thousands of
appointments could be canceled over this
two-day period but chemotherapy
intensive care and neonatal Services
have all all been protected as it stands
after this two-day walkout nurses are
planning to strike again on the 6th and
7th of February the Royal College of
Nursing initially demanded an increase
of up to 19 to cover soaring inflation
and falls in real-term wages over the
past decade but then said members would
be willing to accept a 10 pay rise with
the Union's leader calling on the
government to meet it halfway let's go
Sherman Freeman Powell is at a picket
line at University College Hospital in
central London so 48 hours now shiman
more to come in February
yes that's why their strike action is
completely underway as you can see
they're around I say between 100 and 200
people on this picket line this morning
invigorated by cars that are driving
past and beefing their horns in
solidarity with the Striking nurses not
just cars we've had ambulance and police
cars also people in their horns to give
a nod to the Striking nurses that they
are on their side and the General
Secretary of the Royal College of nurses
has said that the nurses out here
striking are doing so with a heavy heart
she claims they don't want to be taking
strike action but this is the only way
she thinks the government may take
notice sit down around the table and
negotiate pay and this is why nurses are
striking it's open pay and it's over
working conditions I'm joined Now by a
nurse who has been in the profession for
over a decade working at the NHS good
afternoon David can you explain to me
what you mean when you say that working
condition easy to approve what exactly
are you facing on the front line the
reality that will cause of nurse members
are facing every single day not just on
strike days it's every single shift from
understand so what does it actually mean
then for patients it means that your
medicine will be delayed patients who've
got an Uber in pain will not be having
their medicines before two or three
hours patients are actually sitting in
their bodily fluids for a number of
hours because we don't have enough staff
on the ground to provide basic nursing
care for what about other services we're
talking about the the huge waiting list
that exists the reality is is that we
don't have the actual Workforce to
deliver the actual operations
unfortunately if you had cancer you've
got the diagnosis you're ready to start
your chemotherapy but we don't have
enough chemotherapy nurses to actually
deliver the chemotherapy cancer services
this is the reality of nursing morale is
Rock Bottom we're still recovering from
covert nurses my nurse colleagues have
died morale has been what bottom at the
moment the reason why my nurse members
are here today
and ultimately we're defending the NHS
and we're here to patient safety
and explain what that feels like then
you've just said to me that you've been
in the profession for 10 years you
wanted to be a nurse to help people but
you're coming across patients that sat
in their own visually fluids how do you
go home and reflect on your day's work
it's exhausting it's mentally
emotionally and physically
no doubt about it nursing is a tough
tough job it's physically grueling the
shifts are 12 and a half hours long so
after you've gone home you're completely
mentally and emotionally washed down and
then you're often going to bed and
facing it all over again for four shifts
in a row that is a reality that my RCN
members are facing day in day out now
Stephen bark is going to be focusing on
we can't be paying people's style we're
going to be removing money from the
nursing budget playing nurses against
cancer patients it's not a case of
racing to the bottom of how low that we
can pay nurses my message to Steve
Barkley is to do the job you need to
work hard to see Barclay do the job that
you're paid to do with the health
secretary and get rounded negotiation
table meet views so we get a fair pay
deal for nursing and safe Staffing we're
all here today to protect Patient Care
thank you so much David and as I say
there are I would say roughly around 100
to 200 nurses that are on this picket
line taken strike action throughout the
course of today and tomorrow and they
say that if a government don't sit
around the table and open negotiations
overpay then they're prepared to walk
out again on the 6th and 7th of February
okay shiman thank you so much
well joining me now is the GMB National
secretary Rachel Harrison we saw who
made that announcement um at the top of
the hour Rachel thank you so much for
joining us why do you think it's
necessary to add these four new dates
well it's obviously uh clear that the
government are refusing to come to the
table and talk to us about pay so our
members wanted to send this message that
we will continue with this dispute as
long as they allow it to so by sending
this message we hope they will take us
seriously come to the table and start to
talk to us about pay
and what specifically do you want
we want an offer on pay to resolve this
year's dispute what we were asking for
at the start of this process 12 months
ago was a significant increase that
recognized the true value of our NHS
workers and and a planning place to
restore the decade of lost earnings that
they've had without a true investment in
the workforce now they will continue to
leave the service in their thousands so
you can invest as much money into the
services you want but without the
workforce there to deliver waiting times
will continue to increase Handover
delays will continue to increase and
patient safety standards will continue
to deteriorate so we need an investment
in the workforce now and that starts
with a significant offer on this year's
pay and a commitment to talk to us about
next year's pay
they will reply and they have been
throughout this process that we want to
be as reasonable as possible but it's
unaffordable and if we give you the
payrolls that you're asking for
double-digit pay Rises it will embed
inflation the economy will be you know
the inflation will be out of control
excuse me the economy will continue to
suffer and we simply cannot afford it
will we dispute about the impact it
would have on the economy these NHS
workers
um pay taxes themselves they spend any
money they earn within the local
communities that they live so we would
argue against that but what we will say
we cannot afford not to invest in the
workforce we have already seen them
leaving in their thousands there are
over a hundred and thirty three thousand
vacancies across the NHS and that is why
services are suffering because we
literally do not have the workforce
there to deliver the care we need to so
we cannot afford not to invest in the
workforce tell them to come and tell us
what they think is Affordable and then
we can have real negotiations and we can
get a genuine offer that we can take
back to our members
well Robert generic told us this morning
that he he thinks well he said it would
be the worst thing that we could do if
the government met the demands of trade
unions and increased pay by double
digits the worst thing we could do
well I think the worst thing we can do
is let our NHS crumble as it is doing
right now beneath our fees we all will
need our health and care services at
some point and it is our right to
protect them and our members want to do
that one of the reasons they are taking
this action is because they are tired of
being prevented from delivering the safe
standards of care that they want to so I
disagree with that comment I think the
worst thing we can do is not valuing our
NHS workers
they continually say we understand the
pressures that you're under that you are
under we understand that the NHS has
issues they've put a lot of money into
it for 14.1 billion pounds they say
there is a record number of nurses and
doctors Rishi sunak himself today in
pmqs said that there are specific and
practical things we are doing to improve
ambulance times and they are clear
they're investing more in Urgent and
emergency care to create more bed
capacity ensuring that the flow of
patients through Emergency Care is
faster than it ever has been they are
saying they are doing things
well we would question what it is that
they're doing where they're investing
that money and how quickly they're
addressing that issue but all of that is
irrelevant if the workers are not there
to deliver the services and that's the
point that they keep missing we don't
believe they're doing enough they need
to come and actually visit these
workplaces the pressures are real we
have members sitting in ambulances
outside accident and emergency
departments for their entire shift that
is not safe care they are those are the
issues that are not being addressed and
declaring that there's going to be
hundreds thousands more beds in order to
clear hospitals is pointless if there
isn't the staff there in the community
to care for those patients once they've
been discharged the only way the
government are seriously going to
address the crisis that we're facing
across Health and Care is by speaking to
the unions addressing our concerns and
making a real investment into to this
Workforce and that starts with talking
pain now
and what do you say to the response well
to the argument that by going on strike
you are going to put more lives in
danger the people that you say you are
protecting you are going to put them in
danger
not life and limb but you're going to
put other people in danger
well what we can say is that people are
being put in danger every single day due
to the fact that this government has
chosen to deliberately underfund and
under-resource the NHS we have waiting
times for ambulance as ambulances and
Emergency Care increasing our waiting
list across hospitals are increasing our
Handover delays are increasing there is
statistics out there produced by
organizations such as the association of
ambulance Chiefs Executives that shows
the delays are causing significant
patient harm on a day-to-day basis now
the NHS has earned statistics from the
previous strike day shows their access
to Emergency Care actually improved on
strike days and that is thanks to our
members putting emergency procedures in
place to ensure patients could access
emergency care if they needed so what I
would say is the government are putting
patients at risk every single day and
they continue to do that whilst they're
refusing to speak to twice okay Miss
Harrison thank you so much for talking
to us
thank you
right well with all the strike
announcements you can get a full list of
all the strikes taking place across the
country scan this QR code there it is
the bottom of the screen now